hey youtubers is Charlie and there's
only two more episodes of Game of
Thrones this season and since we spent
so much the hiatus doing theorycrafting
I wanted to do a bonus video for all my
favorite prophecies so I'm just
including things that are considered
actual prophecies so if Tyrion had a
wine-soaked nightmare about being
forcibly married to the mountain as a
result of losing the trial by combat
that would not be a prophecy so there
are over 50 that I know of on this show
this is going to be my top 5 I can
always do another video with a bunch
more later this summer though because
there are a ton of them don't forget a
new round of the giveaway will start
whenever I post my episode 9 review
tonight I'll just be picking a random
subscriber from the comments it's not a
contest or anything it's just my way of
saying thank you to all you guys for
being so awesome so time for some Theory
crafting for all these prophecies I'm
gonna say who it's about as well as
where you can find them in the books if
you want to read the full thing because
a lot of these will be condensed so here
we go number 5
Maggy the Frog so Cersei casually
mentions her name on the show out of
context and it's a little confusing but
in the books maggie was a fortune teller
in Lannisport that Cersei visited when
she was 10 with two of her childhood
friends it was all wow this big
tournament for King Aerys was going on
the Mad King so Maggie let Cersei asked
her three questions but she gave her
four answers she predicted who Cersei
would marry Robert not Rhaegar who had
actually just been knighted Rhaegar that
is he was about seven years older than
Cersei Maggie predicted that Cersei
would eventually become queen but that a
younger more beautiful Queen would come
along and take everything that she held
dear the theories behind this are that
the younger queen is either Margaery or
Daenerys in the books Margaery isn't
supposed to be more beautiful than
Cersei but because of the purple wedding
and Cersei a suggestion that she married
Tommen it's still a pretty even guess as
to who that younger more beautiful Queen
is Maggie then went on to predict the
total number of children that both
Robert and she would have separately
obviously because Robert had a ton of
bastards shout out for Gendry who's
still floating out there somewhere south
of Dragonstone the important thing to
remember is that she specifically
predicted the living number of Circe's
children she did have a stillborn child
with Robert Maggie didn't say she would
lose a child but she did predict the
total number and her three plus Robert's
bastards hit that total number I won't
say what the actual total number of
Robert
bastards is just in case the show
changes something there was one more big
part that relates to the valonqar which
is the high Valyrian word for little
brother which is obviously Tyrion but
I'm not going to include that in this
video just in case it's kind of spoilery
if you want to read the whole prophecy
it's in feast for crows pages 540 to 541
number for the winget snake this is one
of brand's visions at the end of book 2
in it
his eyes are clouded with smoke and ash
and he sees a winged snake breathing of
river of flame in the sky rising from
Winterfell because of the timing and
when this vision occurred a lot of
people take the smoke and ash to mean
the burning of Winterfell like we see in
the opening credits every week as for
the dragon there's a couple of theories
the craziest is that there is a dragon
underneath Winterfell that has just laid
dormant forever and the destruction of
Winterfell woken their hot springs mates
Winterfell so it's possible but not
probable the other theory is that it's
just more evidence for Jon Snow being a
Targaryen and that he is the dragon
rising from Winterfell it's open to
interpretation but as a tangent Jojen
claims that visions can be wrong but
greensight is not and brain and Jojen
are both supposed to have the power of
greensight which implies that all of
brans visions are much closer to the
truth than other characters of course
judgin could also be misinterpreting his
claim about greensight but you can read
it in book to page 699 number 3 Azure ah
hi this prophecy comes from Melisandre
and it's always mentioned in the same
sentence with the sword Lightbringer
but azure and light bringer are actually
two separate prophecies azores eye is
like the promised chosen one the one
that's supposed to lead the army of the
red God against the White Walkers and
the great other the text of the prophecy
literally reads when the red star bleeds
and darkness gathers azor Ahai shall be
born again amid smoke and salt the red
star represents the comet which we saw
at the very end of season 1 the darkness
gathering is a reference to the coming
battle with the great other like the
long night the last great battle with
the White Walkers I'll have a link to
that video in the description if you
want to learn more about it Melisandre
tells Stannis that he is aura high
because they're on Dragonstone
the place of smoke and salt but
alternatively that person could be
Daenerys who was literally born as a
child the Dragons
zone for anyone who hasn't read the
books Dragonstone is the ancestral
Westerosi based home of the Targaryen z'
obviously they really came from the
Valyrian freehold but you understand my
meaning we should also remember that
azor Ahai is a person that has to be
reborn so if you want to think about
Daenerys as a Zora hi
you have to look at that scene from
season 1 wherever she stepped into
Drogo's funeral pyre and emerged with
the Dragons that was when the comet
first appeared she wept salt tears you
get the smoke from drugless flames and
she was reborn as the mother of dragons
it doesn't guarantee that she is aura
high but it makes a really strong case
in case you ever wanted to argue with
your friends if you want to read it in
the books it's book 3 page 289 number 2
the daughter of death this is a Daenerys
prophecy from the house of the undying
and because there were so many
prophecies that came out of that I'm
just going to condense a lot of these so
the title of this prophecy daughter of
death comes from the passage that reads
mother of dragons comma daughter of
death so the first part of this is where
Daenerys is seeing the deaths of a lot
of people close to her including her
brother Rhaegar she sees him uttering
his dying words Robert killed him at the
Ruby Ford in the Trident we don't
actually know what the last words were
but the prophecy said that he did
whisper a woman's name the best theory
being Lyanna Stark if Robert heard him
saying it it's not something he would
have ever told anyone since he was in
love with Liana himself then Daenerys
had a vision of Lightbringer the
mythical sword of his aura high the
flaming sword but it was being held by a
blue-eyed King the cast no shadow yes it
sounds a lot like the white Walker we
saw at the end of episode 4 but the
stronger theory I think is that it
represented the shadow baby that killed
Renly since that was happening around
the same time that Daenerys was having
these visions it also suggests that
Stannis and Daenerys might meet at some
point in the future for better or worse
there are a lot of potentially spoilery
parts to our visions that relate to the
mummer's dragon and the stone dragon so
I'm just going to skip over those please
if you're a book reader use the spoiler
tag if you want to talk about them in
the comments the rest of her visions are
things that might have happened had her
baby Rago lived or things that we've
already seen on the show like the
liberation of her army in Yong Chi the
whole prophecy is a collection of like
17 different passages that deal with
stuff from book 1 to potentially the end
of the series so if you want to read the
whole thing be careful for potential
spoilers
but the whole thing is in book 2 from
pages 5:15 to 5:16 and it's like the
whole epic house of the undying visions
and finally my number one favorite
prophecy the dragon has three heads a
lot of people refer to this as the three
heads of the Dragon as if there are
three different characters one of the
rooms Daenerys sees her visions in in
the house of the undying is of Rhaegar
and Elia of Dorne with a newborn baby
Aegon the one the mountain is supposed
to have killed so the interesting thing
about Rhaegar children is that master
amon up at the wall said that Rhaegar
believed his children were the
fulfillment of the azure Ahai prophecy
so the three heads of the Dragon and
azor Ahai are really just two parts of
the same prophecy in Daenerys vision
Elia asks regard of play a song and he
says this is the prince who was promised
and his is a Song of Ice and Fire
then he turned up looked at Daenerys and
said there must be one more the dragon
has three heads so you have to remember
that Rhaegar was naming his children
after Aegon the Conqueror and his two
sisters but obviously they only had two
and they were both believed to be killed
by the mountain so he was intending to
have one more baby girl that doesn't
necessarily mean that Rhaegar children
were the three heads of the Dragon
George are Martin has stated that the
three heads of the Dragon need not all
be Targaryen
but really big asterisk a lot of people
including myself think that Martin is
just being a little bit clever when he
says something like that meaning that
there could be characters alive on the
show that belonged to other houses right
now that do not know that they are
Targaryen if anything's clear on Game of
Thrones is that even highborn people
sleep around just look at Cersei Jon
Snow is the most famous theorized
Targaryen but I have my theory about who
I think the other one is I don't want to
say who in the video but if you want to
comment on who you think it is just use
the spoiler tag in the comments below
in my opinion it's one of the most
popular things to theory craft in the
fandom so it's a ton of fun so I'll be
posting my episode 9 review tonight
after the episode airs be sure to
subscribe to get it
I'm usually pretty good at getting those
videos about 10:00 p.m. Pacific time but
because YouTube has been super buggy
lately if you're worried about missing
it you can either follow me on social
there links to that in the description
below or you can just Park it on the
subscription page or sign up for alerts
so right now click here to get that
episode 9 video of the annotation as
soon as I post it and click here for
Mondays
QA thank you so much for watching I'll
see you guys tonight high fives
[Music]